why do you think the market tanked 633
yesterday Tom why do you think the
market Tank's 633 yesterday the stock
market hates uncertainty and there is a
tremendous amount of automated trading
and the automated Traders you know they
plug things into these into their models
based making like a weather forecast
they look at interest rates they look at
unemployment they look at Supply costs
and they plug those in and there's oh
and when there's uncertainty you can
almost see when all these algorithms and
the programmatic trading refreshes it
was up 300 in the morning the more
remember and the more it went all of a
sudden it starts tipping and it's
because there they look at momentum they
look at a lot of things the market hates
uncertainty and the market says we have
we are not certain about how we're going
to be governed and legislated and more
uh regulated is the way the businesses
pronounce it we don't know what's going
to happen there because we don't know
the outcome of these elections here here
in here and when they plug that
uncertainty in there what happens is
they sell current positions and when you
see what's going on today with the stock
market yeah I'm sending that Adam just
showed it to me
850. yeah so basically you're up to 880
in the market today yep everything's up
big big Dow Jones up 800 S P up 156.
NASDAQ Russell ethereum Amazon Tesla
Disney Nvidia Apple meta go everything
up big big big big big big big the only
thing that's down today the only thing
what what Bitcoin how weird is that yep
so Pat was right Pat yesterday we should
have bought as much [ __ ] as we could
yesterday was the day yeah but when it
was down you know I rang the bell at
NASDAQ since I last saw it wow how was
that I've had a good year that was wrong
it was incredible it was this was about
a month and a half ago went to New York
and I so locals which was my tech
company that I started to fight big Tech
we merged with Rumble Rumble through
SPAC it was basically the only spec of
the year that actually the thing is it
was so supposed to and uh yeah about a
month and a half ago went there that's
sick rang the bell and what was super
cool about it was I used to do stand up
at a little comedy club that we started
it was underneath TGI Fridays in New
York 49th and uh Broadway which was
right next to Lehman Brothers which then
obviously became Barclays and whatever
else it is now uh but I used to stand
out there two hours a night six nights a
week handed out tickets to comedy shows
when I had no freaking money I was
barking I I was broke I was broke I had
a friend who worked in Food Service who
used to just deliver me giant industrial
cans of tuna that's what I lived on for
like 10 years probably gonna die of
mercury poisoning
right now but uh but literally two
blocks away from that I'm ringing the
bell 15 years later that's the American
dream you were super liberal at eating
that tuna at that point no I was I was a
lib I was eating a lot of tuna by the
way
I was talking about talking about spax
uh truth social the day he announced
he's going to be announcing his
presidency next week
stock went up 66 percent in a day then
right after super Tuesday midterms uh
his stock dropped 28 okay 22 to 28 the
following days so his facts yesterday
yeah so yes so so he checked to see
where it's at today the SPAC but it went
66 when he announced that he's
announcing it's Dua because you know how
Trump does that he announces to announce
to announce so he's uh but yeah his back
uh had a good day and then it had a bad
day after the turnout so so town now
that the Market's up 888 what the hell
is going on now well you'll see decent
Cycles sometimes this is called a dead
cat bounce in uh Trader parlance So
Yesterday things go down and then
there's a perception that things are on
sale and so now you add a lot of
momentum right out of the gate making a
purchase I don't think it'll stay this
800 for the to the end of the day I
think it's going to settle back but this
is this is our stock market it gets
spooked one day and then things are down
enough and it says hmm I think some of
these things may be you know what I can
make a little I can make a little play
here and
people you said they said if the the
inflation is going to come at 7.9 if it
comes at seven point and not 7.9 they're
not worried that Powell's gonna
overreact it's still going to increase
interest rates in December but not
dramatically but if inflation comes
eight or higher he may increase by a
point by one basis point in December and
a lot of people are panicking
specifically in the real estate World
half a point is seems to be locked in
right now well here's breaking news from
Wall Street Journal this is 10 minutes
ago inflation eased to 7.7 in October as
underlying price increases including
excluding energy and food slowed down
from four decade High well guess what
yesterday things were down appear like
they're on sale now they get
confirmation that they're probably not
going to get that one point it'll be the
half a point that they've already got
Market reacts up it has certainty that
it's going to be a half Point not a full
point because so what all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]